what oh yes hi uh I'm Glenn pal and I'm
Sydney Sweeney and this is wired
autocomplete
interview uh is Sydney Sweeney and Glen
pal related I really hope not
[Music]
ah no you hold it oh I hold it okay how
was Sydney swy discovered I auditioned a
bunch I mean I started when I was 12 I
auditioned
for everything you could possibly
imagine and then finally everything
sucks and uh sharp objects in HBO
happened when I was like 19 and that
kind of helped catapult and then I did
handm for you straight to the top City
sweetie valid dictorian I forgot about
this yes I was valadi dictorian you'll
find out very quickly Sydney is very
good at absolutely everything
stop Sydney Sweeney Rolling Stones
Rolling Stones okay uh yeah I sh a
really cool music video for their song
Angry just hair flipping down Sunset
hard I um I called you and I was like
guess what I'm doing shutting down
Sunset they asked me first actually I
was unavailable
unavailable uh is Sydney Sweeney and
Glen pal related I really hope not ah um
no I don't think so I haven't done the
23 in me should we no they just got
hacked it's not the time to do 23 and me
there are better uses of your spit for
let's do the next one is Sydney Sweeney
coming back to
Euphoria yeah she's coming back to
Euphoria y Cassie's back Cassie's back
oh who I'm holding yours I think are you
holding mine Glen
Powell it's me oh you Peele where was
Glenn Powell born Austin Texas favorite
place on the planet I was born and
raised there the family's there Texas
Longhorn's there going to the playoffs
let's go hook them oh my God to a all
right how did Glenn Powell get into
acting little movie called Spy Kids 3D
game Over oh my God I grew up watching
that yeah Oscar nominated who did Glen
pal play in Top Gun do you know who I
played in Top Gun I went I saw what
character I saw it twice I went to the
theaters and saw it twice what's what's
my call sign hang man you're damn right
why does Glenn Powell look
familiar I don't know your guess is as
good as mine I don't know okay next I'm
terrified for these Google ones okay
where do s me to grow up I grew up in
Spokane Washington it's right on the
border of Idaho and Washington and it's
a cute little town I loved it just a
small town girl what is Sydney sweetie
filming in Australia ooh I'm filming my
second movie there this year it's called
Eden we're on Howard directing it and
then I filmed anyone but you with Glenn
I want to say that our movie is more fun
it's more it's definitely a little more
but Ron Howard is also very cool he was
really cool but imov is it's really fun
what oh god what
language speak speak um so in high
school I taught myself Russian I was
really really good at it and then I took
Spanish for most of my life and my dad
lives in Mexico so I can speak Spanish
pretty well can you give me one word in
Russian say it to the camera but very
intimidatingly no all right who is
Sydney Sweeney playing in Madam
web um I am playing Julia Carpenter
AKA AKA spider
one toss it oh my off the camera I it
was under
lens okay wait it's my turn as was Glen
Powell a pilot a pilot on screen off
screen I fly at all we did this really
cool uh simulator of a helicopter
remember when we were in the helicopter
and you guys were like hey is that a
normal sound and because I fly enough to
know that it wasn't a normal sound and I
found out was not we were about to crash
it was an emergency landing I would have
died in a helicopter accident and no one
would have reported it cuz I would have
died with Sydney Sweeney all right Glen
Powell I yes what's my color you have
like blue green
eyes blue green eyes yeah you're right I
think blue yeah you have outro of blue
and then 's green the things you learned
I thought it was just Green Glen pal
mom yeah Cindy is the best yeah uh Mama
pal she's very popular I would arguably
say the best pal why would you not
Google Glen
palom I don't know but I'd actually like
to meet the people that are Googling
that on a regular basis I like it I like
that for her yeah all right was Glen pal
in a fraternity I was of course he was
Sigma 5 Epsilon University of Texas I'll
teach you the secret handshake off
camera okay okay Glenn Powell latest
movie latest movie coming out December
22nd anyone but you saring Sydney
Sweeney and Glen PA the guy from sream
crens uh where's your oh oh God uh wait
do I hold it yeah God why do I keep
forgetting the rules every time does
Sydney sweet
actually ice skate no I do not you don't
know how to ice skate well no I do but I
can't do what like the crazy tricks and
all that but I can ice skate like I
could go down to Central Park and go see
this is why Sydney's like really good at
everything just cuz you can't do like a
triple axle you don't think say I I
would say I can ice skate I can barely
stand up does Sydney Sweeney do MMA I do
I do I started training when I was about
12 years old with Rhonda rousa sise and
I really liked it did Sydney Sweeney win
and Emmy no I was nominated for two
emmies though robbed get it right this
year what makeup does Sydney Sweeney use
Armani I love Armani I use their
luminous silk Foundation every day it's
my
favorite same does Sydney Sweeney fix
cars yes I I do I work on cars I have a
1969 Bronco yeah it's sick that's really
cool and then I have an old Mustang too
and a couple others um I completely
worked on the Bronco built it it was uh
a manual and unfortunately in La people
aren't the best drivers and it's very
difficult dealing with that so I had to
turn it into an automatic and my mom
who's standing in the hallway will kill
me because I did that it's
also not inconspicuous no that's you
driving around that it's like a it's
like a beacon my license plate is hey
said not disappearing in that Bronco
yeah all right we're just losing it here
can Glen Powell sing no yes he can he's
lying to you my little sister lesie pal
amazing singer she is an amazing singer
but she stole all that Talent that's so
not true do you do any singing in this
current
movie yeah I think it's a good example
of the fact that I can't not this is not
a good example of the singing Natasha
betting fi capabilities no one can sing
that other than Natasha Glen
Powell my son
my son brisket we love brisket uh my
newly adopted puppy um he's adorable
he's the best decision I've ever made
he's out in the hallway actually he's
out in the hallway if you can feel that
adorable love emanating into the room
Glen
pal C
me uh you'll never lift that down
honestly I don't know who started this
but this has become this has gotten out
of hand I apparently I look like a cppy
Bora uh do you know how this thing
started huh so that that picture of of
me like like looking high on the red
carpet I um wasn't invited to the hidden
figures Premiere but I told them that I
actually just happened to be in New York
so I stopped by and I groomed myself and
like was just a little too excited to be
there that's what happens you look like
a c bar I groom myself like a like a
rodent Glen pal cowboy hat I've got a
pretty solid cowboy hat collection so
I'm definitely known for uh I'm I'm
definitely known for do you have a cowbo
hat yeah oh okay all right I'm just
making sure Glen
pal Top Gun workout oh God I actually
didn't work out it was just coconut oil
you just lather yourself and things just
look better I'm not sure what to say
he's fooling everybody he works out 24/7
no I had to I had to I'm not doing any
more movies with my shirt off I'm done I
I've learned a lot today yeah about
myself and about Sydney the Russian was
new forgot about the Russian you forgot
about the Russian yeah I did I did
there's a lot I mean ice skating thing
you know mhm I'm feeling pretty
unaccomplished here no you're a hangman
don't mom just Glen mom just look up
Glen pal mom or Google OG Glen pal OG
Glen pal that's the next Google
yeah